is it just me or a shailene woodley
actually more attractive without makeup
I mean that's that's impressive
that's the spectacular now stars miles
teller and shailene woodley and this
film is by the writers of 500 days of
summer one of my favorite romantic
comedies which is pretty awesome
basically this movie is about a guy
played by miles teller who's sort of the
life of the party and that's kind of the
characters he's been playing like in 21
and over and Footloose he plays the kind
of guy that's like hey I'm the cool guy
I'm the instigator who's gonna start
everything and he plays that character
in this movie too but it's a little bit
different this time he's getting over a
relationship with another girl when he
runs into shailene woodley who's very
much not his typical style
she doesn't wear much makeup she doesn't
think she's good-looking at all she
reads manga she likes to draw you know
she's the dorky girl who's very
attractive but doesn't really have that
many friends and once a relationship
starts up between these two we get a
very realistic look at young love we get
a good look at youth and how youth have
to deal with many family problems and
the things that come along with that and
the way the script is written and the
way the film is directed is so realistic
to the point where I almost felt
uncomfortable at times watching the
scenes that played out in this movie
because they were so well done the
spectacular now is one of my favorite
films I've seen all year the movie
starts out and what I loved about it was
that it's the kind of film in the kind
of screenplay that doesn't feel the urge
to have all of these humongous moments
until later on but as the film starts
then into the second act this is just
watching the everyday lives of these
people and you can see them get to know
each other and it's so not Hollywood
eyes and I love that about the way they
approach the relationship between these
two characters and you get to learn more
about each of their family backgrounds
as well it's not just this romance and
only this romance miles teller scare
achter has a broken family shailene
Woodley's character also has a broken
family and you get to see how all of
these things affect these people's lives
and one of the great themes about this
movie that I loved was how people who
act like they're always on top of things
aren't a lot of them have really
horrible lives and I really like the
script and the way the film is directed
and how it stayed true to that fact
about human nature that most people try
to hide their problems that's one of the
beautiful things about this movie is
it's not just a romantic film it has a
lot of things to say
about not just youth but adulthood both
of those characters were very fun to
watch shailene woodley and my opinion is
oscar-worthy in this movie really she
did such a fantastic job
seeing the descendants and now this I'm
super impressed with this actress I mean
she's so good in this movie so real
miles teller also really came into his
own in this movie because as I said
although he plays that similar character
he's been playing lately that
life-of-the-party fun guy it was almost
like that character that he's been
playing finally matured and blossomed in
this movie and you got to see him
fleshed out and you got to understand
more about him even though he played a
familiar character for a while you could
really see behind his eyes that he was
hiding a lot of pain and it worked so
well in this movie that both of these
actors were fantastic this is one of the
movies where if you don't mind watching
people talk and actually share
interesting dialogue or dialogue and
sometimes really honestly break your
heart you're gonna love this movie and I
loved a movie that actually sits back
and shows people just talking it's
interesting and fun to watch because you
get to learn more about characters and
that's something that's so rare in
movies nowadays you actually get to
learn about characters and things in
their lives you may actually begin to
feel like you are watching people that
exist even though they're fictional this
movie also features one of the most
realistic love scenes I've ever seen I
was very impressed with the way it was
approached and that's all I'm going to
say about that but it just felt so real
and that was something that I really I'm
not talking about graphic it just it
felt not Hollywood eyes like I've been
saying it felt genuine I have but one
flaw with the movie and that is that a
certain thing happens that's fairly
surprising that was very effective but
then it just sort of gets glossed over
and you sort of lose a feel of time
almost as the next few scenes progressed
and besides that the spectacular now is
one of my favorite films of the summer
if not the year I'm gonna give it an A I
really think you guys should see it it's
one of the better romance films I've
seen in years definitely check this one
out it's definitely worth your time as
always guys thanks a lot for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes she really
wants to be in the video I don't know
why but this is my new cat her name is
Vesper and she really will not stop
looking at my microphone
[Music]